bonsoir à tous et bonne année bienvenue
dans le 7-8 sport l'émission consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
tout de suite le sommaire de votre
émission
football le club demande dernière écrit
pivi noise encore en course en coupe de
france a réussi l'exploit de se
qualifier pour les 16e de finale de la
compétition en battant le stade briochin
et détail dans cette édition
handball les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux promu cette année
en nationale une pointe à la 10e place
du championnat la mi saison pour nous
parler du club et ses objectifs nous
recevrons les coaches n'est joué dans ce
magazine golf un joueur originaire de
montigny-le-bretonneux pourrait devenir
numéro 1 français dans quelques années
benjamin j'ai 21 ans vient de passer
golfeur professionnel il vient
d'intégrer la 3e division européenne
portrait à suivre
et puis l'essentiel de l'actualité du
sport évinois nous parlerons notamment
automobile et du 4l trophy n'gouan
courtoise prendra le départ de l'épreuve
ils l'ont fait le club demande dernière
équipe évinoise encore en course en
coupe de france a réussi l'exploit de se
qualifier pour les 16e de finale de la
compétition en battant le stade briochin
le score de 8 à 0
retour sur cette qualification les
images sont signés à fanny bourdillon
une victoire historique le fc mantois 78
club de cfa a réussi l'exploit de se
hisser en seizièmes de finale de la
coupe de france en battant difficilement
sur son terrain le stade briochin une
équipe de cfa2 le score 2 buts à 0 avec
des réalisations de francis massampu
hébreu l'opéra dans les arrêts de jeu
une qualification au forceps sur le
match on peut pas se vanter d'avoir été
au dessus au dessus on a eu la chance
d'ouvrir le score un bon moment de la
partie à prendre a subi mais bon en
coupe ce qui compte c'est de passer des
regrets d'avoir encaissé ce but là parce
que finalement ils nous marquent le but
sur leur seule demi-occasion c'est même
pas une véritable occasion donc le
regret il est là félicitations mantois
c'est eux qui ont gagné ils sont passés
même si
on peut considérer qu'on a été meilleurs
que sur ce match là mais au final c'est
moi qui seront 16e donc félicitations
avec cette victoire le fc mentaux a
écrit l'une des plus belles pages de son
histoire depuis sa création en 1994 le
club n'avait jamais dépassé le stade des
32e de finale de la coupe de france
c'est sûr que les gens vont retenir
c'est la qualification et même dans 10
ans on pourra dire qu'on a fait 1 16e
pour ceux qui l'ont vécue c'est vrai que
c'était difficile en 16e de finale le
dernier représentant évinois de cette
coupe de france pourrait recevoir à la
maison des clubs de ligue 1 comme le
paris saint germain monaco lyon ou
encore marseille
ce qu'on souhaitait déjà c'était
attendre des seizièmes de finale
maintenant qu'on est en compte y est
pourquoi pas une ligue 1 et pourquoi pas
un voisin attendant le psg mais ça c'est
le souhait de n'importe quel club en
france
réponse ce lundi 4 janvier à 19h30 pour
le tirage les supporteurs ne demandent
qu arriver
après le football on passe au handball
coup de projecteur sur les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux
le club de montigny le bretonneux a
réussi à se hisser cette saison en
national une première depuis dix ans
après un départ canon avec deux
victoires en trois matches disputés les
i montagne patine et pointe à la 10e
place du classement à la mi-saison pour
nous parler du club nous recevons sur
ses pattes plateau le coach philippe
l'étrange et la joueuse mégane étrange
bonsoir alors je le disais précédemment
vous aviez très bien commencé la saison
et puis un coup d'arrêt d'un seul coup
au bout de trois journées
comment l'expliquez vous par plein de
choses déjà on avait rencontré des
équipes qui jouent le bas de classement
comme nous donc au début et puis on a eu
beaucoup de bus et des départs donc
c'est un peu compliqué la chose et
départ c'est-à-dire il ya eu notamment
je crois car limiter les heures qui
était un pilier on va monter un dossier
et voir la meilleure buteuse qui a été
muté en allemagne donc est parti et puis
après on a eu de blessés tout le temps
tout au long jusqu'au mois de décembre
donc j'espère les récupérer là pour
entamer les matches très importants la 2
de janvier février
ce départ de carol limiter les heures
vous aperture vais vous le groupe a
perturbé le groupe
ben c'était un pilier on savait qu'on
pouvait se reposer sur elle quand
l'équipe allait un peu moins bien ça
allait prendre le jeu à son compte
sûr qu'on a perdu une très bonne joueuse
on avait un peu du mal à s'en remettre
on avait aussi à ses traits à égalité
contre angoulême où c'était on pensait
avoir passé 24 au final on perd encore
donc on espère que ça aille mieux alors
janvier jeu ce qui est parti pour les
réseaux professionnels du coup oui
et du coup le on va dire son efficacité
offensive parce que c'était vraiment une
buteuse s qui qui la remplace en fait au
final dans l'effectif bassine jeunes qui
revient de à montigny qui était parti en
belgique pour ses études
donc et en-cas 21 ans donc encore temps
ça va le faire il n'y a pas de souci
mais bon là n'a pas l'expérience qu'avec
que pouvait revoir carole mais on espère
sur elle sur les matches à venir et où
le disais précédemment il est également
beaucoup de blessés notamment fanny jean
baptiste venise également y jouer c'est
très important dans l'effectif match
solide à lou bénézis tremblay s'était
beaucoup blessée blessée et comment
expliquez vous cela
les blessures c'est peut-être la cliente
à sion au niveau de la nationale une
certainement peut-être qu'on joue en
surrégime et on se laisse plus
facilement qu'elle est différent
justement égales entre le niveau de la
nationale 2 et d'un niveau national une
c'est plus physique ça va plus vite
c'est plus physique ça joue plus vite on
se prend plus de coups il ya des bonnes
choses à tous les postes ya jamais un
poste où vous dis là c'est un peu moins
fort sur celui là il faut qu'on la
laisse tirer y avait vraiment développer
des bonnes choses par sue c'est
compliqué au niveau physique
et est-ce qu'ils étaient des regrets
peut-être sur certaines rencontres je
pense notamment au match contre
angoulême la juste avant en décembre ce
match que vous avez finalement quand
vous avez finalement faire match nul 32
partout ce match vous l'avez maîtriser
vraiment de bout en bout quasiment et
c'est sur les dernières secondes
peut-être que vous avez conseil de ce
match nul
est-ce qu'il ya pas de regrets justement
sur ce type de match basse il ya des
regrets on a perdu image enfin on a fait
qualité de soin match dans les cinq
dernières minutes c'est vrai qu'on avait
match de la veille va porter de nuuk
quoi mais bon après elles ont le niveau
elles ont l'expérience à 100 su garder
espoir jusqu'à la dernière minute
et nous on pensait que c'était peut-être
acquis trop vite on a peut-être lâché à
la fin je ne sais pas après égalité 1
c'est mieux que perdre mes succès un peu
de regrets quand philippe piat également
certains matches qui vous restent en
travers la gorge
ben goulaine
on a fait un bon match à rennes contre
les premiers ou on perd que de trois
buts en faisant un bon match
alors c'est vrai que c'est encore une
c'est une défaite mais il faut qu'on se
base sur ces matches là pour travailler
pour l'avenir
pour gagner les points là on a besoin de
points en janvier et en février il faut
qu'on marque des points
donc vous maintient donc on vous avait
reçu au mois de septembre pour justement
pas reparler de la saison vous m'aviez
annoncé le maintien comme objectif est
ce que ça sera toujours le maintien mais
où est-ce que vous visez quand même un
petit peu plus haut non le maintien ce
serait très bien
après si on commet en terminant 10e on
l'a on se maintient si on peut terminer
un peu au dessus m'a tant mieux pour
nous maintenant le jeu ray je me répète
mais est-ce que ça va être très
important la janvier et février
on va rencontrer des équipes qui sont de
notre niveau
classé comme nous derrière nous donc
c'est là qu'il faut les mettre loin de
nous si on veut s'en sortir
pareil pour megan ce sera le maintien et
rien d'autre le maintien après ce 12e
gagner une ou deux places ça serait bien
pour nous mais le championnat est quand
même assez sérieux le championnat est
très serré après on est capable de
gagner comme des équipes qui sont au
tableau et perdre comme si l'équipe
cadets qui sont en concurrence avec nous
donc va falloir qu'on se soude et puis
qu'on essaie de gagner plus de points
possibles bien ce que vous pensez que
vous avez l'effectif pour je pense qu'on
a l'effectif on a beaucoup progressé
depuis le début de l'année des bonnes
choses aussi à tous les postes donc je
pense que c'est possible
le groupe est assez jeune philippe c'est
un choix de montigny oui c'est un choix
je dirais presque obligé obligé mais non
non c'est un choix nous on est là pour
former des jeunes et je ne pousse si on
peut les amener à ce niveau là c'est
très bien il ya notamment de jose 16 ans
que je crois qu'il ya intégré l'effectif
oui une gardienne de but de saison une
manière de saison 6 qui vous poule à
fleury-les-aubrais donc donc sous russes
et ça c'est l'avenir de mon qu'initie
passe par là et cette jeunesse c'est
peut-être pas le point faible justement
de l'équipe de ce manque d'expérience
certainement certainement déjà qu'il ya
un manque d'expérience peut être à ce
niveau là déjà à la base de beaucoup de
filles pour pas dire tout
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est c'est
d'autres points faibles mais il se doit
nous apporter un point fort d'ici un ou
deux ans donc votre prochain match
il est ce dimanche contre fleury loiret
est ce que c'est un adversaire que vous
connaissez bien pas du tout aller
dossiers des jeunes joueuses de centre
de formation
en plus on va l'aborder avec très peu de
d'entraînement vu qu'on a pas eu de
salle pour s'entraîner pendant les
vacances
donc on va avoir trois entraînements
dans les patins avant d'aller à fleury
puis on verra ce que comment que ça se
passe le savoir c'est un handicap ne pas
avoir joué pendant les fêtes le gymnase
et des fermiers les gymnases a été
fermée donc on fait avec on fait son oui
c'est un handicap certainement
maintenant dont les filles je pense que
savait très bien que je janvier-février
aller dur pour nous est très important
donc je pense qu'à se sont préparés tout
seul média nous avait préparé ce match
pendant les fêtes font pas du tout juste
si on s'était dit qu'il fallait qu'on
aille tout un peu courir garder un peu
de physique même si on aurait pas dû à
un bal notre public c'est quand même
important entre les matchs à tous à être
des jeunes dans l'équipe de fleury c'est
une réserve de dire donc on a tout
essayé d'être un peu sérieuse et à les
découvrir et vous faire un peu de
musculation sur les sept pièces que le
maintien se joue sur ce type de match
oui le maintien va se jouer sur un
maintenant tous les matches - tous les
matches et peut être ce mois de janvier
peut être philippe et peut être crucial
connaître en blanc pour la vie et ce
n'est quelques os qui est prenable
ça peut être prenable après on va à
landi lampaul qui sont derrière nous qui
sont dernière après on reçoit nantes qui
sont un peu au dessus et après on va
carquefou qui sont derrière donc là
c'est très important donc défaite
interdite aux moins contrôler languit
carquefou après si on peut prendre
d'autres points ça serait bien pour se
mettre à l'abri assez rapidement donc
médias vous pouvez nous assurer que
montigny sera encore nationale une année
prochaine on fera tout national et
prochaine pareil pour boufique bah oui
on fera plus tour après le championnat
va parler ici quelques temps merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau vous
souhaite bon courage pour la suite de la
saison
et pour ce premier match je laisse du
coup je le rappelle vous allez affronter
ce dimanche fleury loiret à l'extérieur
on passe à présent au golf
un golfeur originaire de
montigny-le-bretonneux pourrait devenir
numéro 1 français dans quelques années
benjamin j'ai 21 ans vient de passer
professionnel
le sportif participera au programme tour
la 3e division européenne en 2016 le
montage est signé et xavier jamin le
futur tiger woods est peut-être ini
montrent un benjamin jaillet tout juste
22 ans vient d'intégrer le circuit
professionnel
le golfeur qui a débuté sur les greens
suit un stage organisé en 2008 par la
mairie de montigny août ne évoluera
l'année prochaine dans le pro gold tours
l'équivalent de la troisième division
depuis que j'ai démarré golf ça a été
voilà cette idée là de se préparer en
vue un jour peut-être de jouer sur le
circuit pro et aujourd'hui c'est la
première étape voilà donc trois circuits
satellite allemand la 3e division
européenne pour peut-être dans quatre
cinq ans être dans l'élite mondiale du
golf pas du mois c'est l'objectif qui
est fixé depuis deux budgets des marais
golf en tout cas ce golfeur a connu une
ascension fulgurante et atypique en sept
ans benjamin est passé du statut
d'amateur à celui de professionnel
le sportif événement est notamment
devenu champion de france par équipes
avec les moins de 17 en 2009
une réussite qu'il doit notamment à son
jeu long c'est vrai qu'il a été reconnu
par plusieurs pros qu'ils ont fait
travailler qu'il a une grosse vitesse de
swing et une frappe assez conséquente
voilà qui peut lui permettre d'atteindre
le meilleur niveau j'ai la chance de
pouvoir frapper assez fort la balle est
relativement droit donc ce qui me permet
même si les parcours sont long jam être
trop en difficulté
après quelques petits soucis au niveau
du petit jeu mais c'est pour ça que
voilà on s'entraîne toujours et qu'on
travaille sur ces points sur ses points
faibles
un jeu court que lenny montrent un
devrait améliorer pour se rapprocher du
niveau de ses idoles le grand classique
tiger woods
quand même inspiré beaucoup de golfeurs
et puis qui reste le meilleur golfeur au
monde donc on va là qui s'en vient un
jour d'arrivée à ceux à ce niveau là
quoi on aspire tous à ça être être mis
au rang mondial après faut de la
patience du travail et prendre sa chance
quand quand on peut l'apprendre et et
avancer benjamin joaillier reprendra la
compétition au mois de mars il devrait
s'aligner sur un tournoi marocain
on continue ce magazine par du basket le
fc trappes saint quentin en yvelines va
entamer la phase retour du championnat
de nationale 3 à la mi saison l'équipe
senior coachée par mustapha el hafidi
est à la septième place avec un bilan de
quatre victoires et six défaites en dix
matches disputés pour nous parler du
club nous recevons sur ce plateau le
meneur a brigué bac à rabat ou bonsoir
bonsoir alors quatre victoires pour 6
défaites
est ce que vous attendez à ce bilan à la
mi-saison attrape alors à la mi saison
il est vrai qu' on aurait aimé peut-être
avoir une ou deux victoires de plus mais
c'est vrai que
au départ avec un groupe en
reconstruction on n'avait pas on s'est
pas fixé d'objectif particulier dont
c'était juste la progression semaine
après semaine
pour l'instant c'est vrai que bon le
bilan n'est pas équilibré mais je pense
que c'est pas non plus un échec et du
mieux il ya du mieux depuis quelques
semaines ya vraiment du mieux encore une
fois les matches qu'on a perdu contre
les équipes derrière nous on les a pas
bien abordé et je pense que si on
continue comme ça ça peut être pas mal
et a surtout vu ce début de saison
compliqué avec un clic et voilà
plusieurs défaites à une série de deux
défaites
exactement donc on savait qu'on n'était
pas prêts au départ parce que c'est
comme je vous ai dit une équipe a
vraiment reconstruction et il ya eu des
matches où on a laissé filer
j'espère qu'on s'en mordra pas les
doigts mais c'était compliqué à gérer
mais on continue à bosser on n'a jamais
lâché et on est en train de payer donc
vous le disais il ya eu beaucoup
d'arrivées dans ce club à l'intersaison
il est notamment dû au cassis le petit
mot de 2011 et vous également qu'il ya
qui est arrivé dans ce club il fallait
peut-être un temps d'adaptation à
l'équipe le temps que la mayonnaise
prenne
voilà dès le départ dans les discussions
avec l'entraîneur il m'avait dit qu'on
serait prêts vraiment vers octobre
novembre
donc on a été près vraiment en octobre à
gagner des matches le problème c'est
qu'on en a laissé filer aussi des
erreurs de gestion tout ça ça va
beaucoup mieux il ya aussi être garé un
ancien de la maison qui arrivent et qui
nous fait beaucoup de bien
l'équipe est plus équilibrée et simon
craie pas grand chose vraiment la
gestion de fin de match et je pense que
ça y est ça ira mieux bon vous vous êtes
le petit nouveau de l'équipe vous sentez
comment la après plusieurs mois dans
cette équipe de trappes
bon moi j'ai trouvé ma place dès le
départ donc
discussion avec nasser pour arriver le
coach beaucoup de discussions avec le
coach comme du capitaine de l'équipe on
essaye de 2,2 tout faire pour que
l'équipe aille dans le bon sens moi je
me sens bien
voilà le terrain est bien les
entraînements sont de très grande
qualité
je pensais pas aussi bien travaillé en
nationale 3 au niveau des entraînements
honnêtement donc voilà après le tout ça
c'est bien mais c'est les victoires qui
qui font que voilà si le travail paye ou
pas parce que vous avez eu un parcours
un peu atypique a trotté voilà alors
j'ai connu le haut niveau et le est un
peu des moments de galère on va dire
voilà moi j'ai les dernières années je
suis resté sur chartres
on a connu la montée de n1 de n2 et n1
j'étais à fos-sur-mer
on a connu la n2 je suis parti de la n2
à la pro b
j'ai connu aussi des blessures j'étais à
strasbourg
en centre de formation et je me suis
blessé donc je me se retrouve en n2 dans
le sud de la france en étant tout jeune
dans un coin perdu mais j'ai toujours
réussi à rebondir quoi donc vous
apportez votre expérience au groupe
j'essaye j'essaye de je parle beaucoup
avec les joueurs on parle beaucoup on
échange
parce que c'est vrai que le jeune et et
le groupe est très jeune
mais avec des qualités beaucoup de
qualités et c'est des jeunes qui sont à
l'écouté qui me coûte pas mal donc
j'essaye de donner mon expérience parce
qu'aussi et donc le groupe vit bien
le groupe vit bien le groupe vit bien ça
à mon groupe voilà comme chaque groupe
la foi et les petites d'accrochages à
l'entraînement mais ça veut dire que
c'est un groupe qui vit
voilà ce qui pourrait faire que le
groupe a et le mieux c'est allah d'avoir
plus grand nombre de victoires le plus
rapidement possible parce que c'est bon
après des défaites on n'a jamais vu
quelqu'un tirer la gueule entraînements
on est toujours resté concentré mais
c'est vrai que ça aide à bien vivre pour
un groupe les victoires c'est indéniable
et que pensez-vous du coach il est
réputé pour être assez dur avec des
entraînements compliqué dur vous c'est
votre philosophie de jeu entraînement
dur compliqué non c'est des
entraînements la sig n'ont pas classe x
et on travaille de manière appropriée
c'est-à-dire qu'on travaille vraiment
la lecture de jeu des choses vraiment
que je pensais pas travailler en
nationale 3 non c'est des choses dures
oui en juin l'encours et tout ça c'est
dans le basket c'est pas à courir dehors
de la salle tout ça et on a une relation
on échange beaucoup voilà on parle de
jeu de basket et moi c'est ce qui
m'intéresse donc non non moi ça se passe
très bien
donc vous êtes 7e est ce qu'on pensait
que tu rappes encore terminer dans le
trio de tête
quand on voit le classement justement on
voit que vous n'êtes qu'à cinq points du
premier jus l'isi sait rien en finale
sait rien on perd là-bas nous embêter
pendant 35 minutes trio de tête
aujourd'hui je préfère même pas me
prononcer là dessus parce que pour moi
je préfère vraiment les victoires les
uns après les autres
après on voit que ça tient en rien les
chiffres les points
ça ça peut aller vite dans un sens comme
dans l'autre
donc on va être prudent là-dessus à
l'expérience me me fera pas donner de
pronostic là dessus donc vous avez joué
ce week-end contre malakoff c'est une
équipe que vous avez l'habitude de jouer
dans ce championnat de nationale 3 est
ce que c'est une équipe que vous
craignez honnêtement on craint personne
c'est pas
c'est pas être prétentieux voilà on ne
peut pas arriver en maths dans un match
avec de la crainte
moi personnellement je les connais pas
parce que je connais pas la première
fois que je joue en nationale 3 mais on
craint personne les juvisiennes équipe
qui mettait 40 points à tout le monde
on y allait pour gagner donc non enfin
personne normalement et qu'elle saura
quelles sont les consignes du coach à
votre avis à ce match la course a
toujours été la même c'est donc non gère
bien le jeu c'est à dire on essaye de ne
pas perdre deux balles de jeu tout en
contrôle et voilà comme d'habitude la
défense qui qui est notre maître mot
défense et jouer tous ensemble pourrait
terminer par un pronostic
à votre avis ça va donner quoi pour
trappe victoire à ses victoires on n'a
pas le choix et aux victoires de combien
directoire tout simple histoire voilà
voilà enfin des deux fois merci merci
d'être passé dans ce plateau c'était un
plaisir de vous recevoir on continuera à
suivre tout au long de la saison votre
club et vos performances bien sûr zuma
présent sur le 4l trophy la 19e édition
du 4l trophy programmée du 18 au 28
février prochain plus de 1300 équipage
composé d'étudiants se sont inscrits
pour ce raid automobile humanitaire
cette année une jument courtoise
laetitia des langues prendra le départ
de cette course qui reliera la france au
maroc
patrick jane de dixmude pour les images
une aventurière des temps modernes
laguian courtoise laetitia des landes 24
ans étudiante en deuxième année de
master s'est lancé le défi de disputer
la 19e édition du 4l trophy une course
d'orientation automobile exclusivement
destiné aux étudiants qui relie la
france au maroc pour s'inscrire à
l'épreuve les participants doivent
collecter en moyenne 7500 euros pour
couvrir les frais d'inscription et la
préparation du véhicule est de sponsors
est donc indispensable
on a voulu en fait s'adressait à des
grandes entreprises
donc au début on a eu beaucoup de noms
en fait énormément de noms donc on n'a
pas baissé les bras mais c'est
démotivant
et puis dans un jour voilà on a eu
beaucoup de vie et puis voilà avec le
contexte plein de choses enfin la
persévérance au final et on a rempli
notre objectif
la compétition est organisée du 18 au 28
février l'illinois se partagera cette
expérience avec sa camarade de classe
anaïs chartier on va tourner
régulièrement tu as trois heures chacune
à chaque fois pour pour se répartir le
temps pour éviter cette pratique juste
avant en fait on assimile kilomètres à
faire pendant dix jours
du coup ça fait une moyenne de 600
kilomètres par jour donc on va alterner
voilà des tonalités fatigué on alterne
et puis après bah oui là on va vivre
ensemble au quotidien on aura une petite
ans donc on va dormir ensemble tous les
soirs sous la tente pour participer à
cette course humanitaire qui consiste à
amener 50 kg de fournitures scolaires au
maroc et des étudiantes ont acheté une
voiture qui a déjà deux 4l trophy à son
actif on a un moteur quand même
relativement simple on a notre batterie
notre équipe de refroidissement on a
deux ventilateurs pour refroidir le
moteur pendant le raid on aura peut-être
le filtre à nettoyer ce qu'il sera
rempli de sable et puis pour le reste
tout est impeccable pour cette première
participation les deux étudiantes vise
le haut du classement
oui j'adore d'espère on est on est
motivés ont des aventurières et on va
rien lâcher
au total plus de 2000 étudiants sont
attendus au village de départ à biarritz
pour participer au 4l trophy 2016 on
passe à présent l'agenda sport du week
end
on commence à pages agenda part du rugby
en promotion d'honneur le sky rugby se
déplacera sur le terrain de l'entente
triel les mureaux pour le compte de la
10e journée du championnat
le match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade de gaston chirac les
saint quentinois doivent remporter ce
match pour conserver la première place
du classement une place de leader
acquise grâce à une victoire contre
clairement lors de la 8e journée
le sky partira favori contre les murs ou
les joueurs coachés par thomas panière
les avait dominés 26 à 3 en octobre
dernier
on reste dans le rugby en première série
montigny-le-bretonneux troisième du
championnat se déplacera sur le terrain
du deuxième l'olympique connu mais rien
le match est programmé au stade des cas
puissance ce dimanche à 15 heures en
seine et marne
objectif pour montigny recoller acculé
connu mais rien qui possède six points
d'avancé sur les yvelinois pour emporter
la victoire les hommes de cyril mûriers
vont essayer de mettre en place leur jeu
offensif l'équipe a déjà inscrit plus de
200 points depuis le début de la saison
on passe au football on jouera ce
dimanche sur le terrain de la division
excellence mort par soit poissy ce
dimanche à 15h heure pour un derby haut
rhinois qui s'annonce sulfuré pour la
lutte pour le maintien est mort passe
bien pointe aujourd'hui à la neuvième
place du classement la raison les
aiglons avaient perdu beaucoup de points
pendant leur campagne en coupe de france
un parcours qui les avaient emmenés
jusqu'au cinquième tour de la
compétition
l'objectif est maintenant de recoller
aux équipes du milieu de classement avec
une victoire contre poissy maurepas
pourrait s'emparer de la 6e place du
classement
les supporters sont évidemment invités à
les soutenir et on termine cet agenda
part du tennis les deux courts couverts
du parc philippe cousteau de la verrière
vont accueillir à partir de ce samedi
plus de 140 joueurs amateurs éclairés à
l'occasion de l'open de tennis de la
ville
cette 13e édition est programmée sur
trois semaines les tennismans à
s'affronteront du 9 au 31 janvier
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci
l'avoir subi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78